[Musique]
prévenus par un autochtone ici c'est
mille seulement lundi cuit aujourd'hui
on est le 30 septembre 2021 première
journée la célébration de la vérité
réconciliation
enfin c'est un congé qui est retenu au
fédéral et est reconnue dans certaines
provinces
mais beaucoup d'autres provinces ne leur
est un espoir officiellement dont le
québec
d'ailleurs on la surnomme aussi la
journée du village d'ailleurs vous
comprendrez mon choix vestimentaires
aujourd'hui et ce choix vestimentaire
bière en l'honneur de silice web stade
qui était une femme la nation cqm baic
qui était la troisième génération de
femmes dans sa famille à aller au
pensionnat et elle se souvient que la
journée la première journée d'école pour
pouvoir aller à l'école elle avait
choisi un jus d'orange très très
brillant et avec sa mère quand il s'est
rendu la première chose qui lui ont
retiré s'était s'agi leurs anges
laquelle n'avait d'ailleurs jamais revu
et à chaque fois qu'il se rappelait de
ce gilet rouge ça venait faire ressortir
sentiment de honte de jeunes d'avoir été
au pensionnat d'avoir été justement
qu'elle n'avait pas de valeur aux yeux
des enseignants ou qu'elle avait
quelqu'un l'apprenait à l'école donc
pour la guérison pour la suite ll parler
de cette histoire et le gilet orange
devenue un symbole justement de
reprendre de guérir de
ceux d affranchir de ce que les
pensionnés années et aujourd'hui c'est
une journée pour célébrer les survivants
des pensionnats et c'est vrai aussi les
générations d'enfants qui existent
aujourd'hui qui grâce à ces survivants
leur apprendre leur langue apprennent
leur culture danse chant ou même
seulement sont en vie car on va se
souvenir que cette année aussi on a
découvert énormément de sites ou
les enfants ne sont jamais rentrés des
pensionnaires ont été enterrées des fois
dans des tombes complètement anonyme
carrément des charniers
et cette réflexion-là de saison afin
qu'ils ne sont pas revenus nous permet
de célébrer les enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui ici pour pouvoir célébrer
chemin la suite le 30 septembre s'est
pas uniquement une journée
[Musique]
de tristesse uniquement une journée de
deuil c'est aussi une journée de
célébration on s'élève le fait est
encore vivant d'être encore là donc si
certains cas le monde me demande comment
est ce que je peux célébrée le 30
septembre c'est une journée qui des fois
et très lourde pour certaines personnes
ne comprennent pas comment on peut
approcher un patient noir ce qui est de
l'histoire et des fondements des
suggestions comment célébrer le 30
septembre 10 soins et des suggestions
très facile lire des livres sur
l'histoire des pensées n'a partagé des
artistes des auteurs des poètes des
firmes la culture autochtone parle de
cette histoire là mais qu'ils pensent du
restant de notre culture il ya beaucoup
de livres d'artistes présentement on a
des recueils de poésie on a le livre ni
nawas est un recueil de poésie écrits
par des enfants aujourd'hui donc sa
célèbre le fait qu'ils aient des enfants
qui existe encore aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
gardé leur langue et c'est grâce aux
survivants des pensionnats et dfm le
cheval un indien il ya des chansons il
ya beaucoup de témoignages qui sont
encore même de la commission
vérité-réconciliation
ça je vous en je vous recommande et ça
c'était un des aspects qui était très
très
important pour moi c'est la transmission
des histoires parce que deuxième
suggestion je préfère c'est justement
d'aider les communautés à transmettre
cette histoire quand j'étais avec la
commission vérité-réconciliation j'étais
responsable à l'époque les médias
sociaux est ce que je voyais le plus
souvent c'était que les personnes des
survivants
étaient particulièrement touchés quand
des personnes allochtone qui n était pas
obligé d'être là venez écouter leurs
témoignages venait écouter leurs
histoires et ne mettait pas en de leur
histoire leur témoignage parce que c'est
arrivé c'est aussi ça ça peut détruire
vraiment une personne quand tu penses
que des nations complète de 209 15 ans
ont décidé d'inventer l'histoire des
pensionnats pour comprendre l'impact que
ça lui si on ne croira jamais mais
beaucoup de gens écouter beaucoup de
gens ont cru et même moi j'ai eu la
chance à mon année de me faire dire je
ne savais pas que ça avait été fait dans
mon pays dans mon canada en mon nom mais
ce que je peux faire aujourd'hui c'est
que je vous promets je vous dirai jamais
que je veux toujours partager cette
histoire est l'effet que ça l'avait eue
sur moi cette époque lui avait été
énorme c'est à dire juste de se faire
croire ça enlevé un poids le fait que
cette histoire là était partagé le pot
cette histoire était partagée enlevé un
poids dont j'étais même pas un sur yon
des pensionnats et pour moi ça a amené
quelque chose de le juge peut même pas
imaginer ça peut faire pour les
survivants des pensionnats partager les
histoires surtout que de plus en plus de
gens vont commencer à célébrer souligné
le 30 septembre il n'y a pas assez de
personnes autochtones qui font des
ateliers pour venir dans toutes les
écoles dans tout dans toutes les
universités décrire toutes mes livres on
a besoin donc de supporter la communauté
qui veut le faire de partage et
justement les témoignages des personnes
qui ont eu à les faire c'est une manière
de porter le poids est de célébrer la
parole encore vivant toujours un
troisième aspect que j'aime beaucoup
suggérer c'est des fois
la voix et le vote autochtone n'est pas
écoutée de la même manière que la voie
où le vote allochtone donc jeudi citant
peut-être de mettre la pression sur vos
gouvernements provinciaux pour que
justement deux reconnaissent la journée
du 30 septembre comme une journée de
recueillement national de célébration
nationale parce que toutes les nations
au canada ont heureusement une journée
ou ce qu on peut se souvenir
je pense par exemple
les
gens se souvenaient ou est ce qu on se
souvient des anciens combattants et des
journées pour célébrer on a une journée
pour célébrer c'est le 21 juin mais
est-ce qu'on a une journée pour se
souvenir et pas uniquement se souvenir
tout seul entre nous autres se souvenir
avec le canada donc de prendre le temps
que le 30 septembre devienne une journée
de souvenir national et pas uniquement
de souvenirs autochtone ça peut être
quelque chose qui va être très fort
c'est de dire vous vous
votre histoire compte autant que la
nôtre est présentement c'est encore peu
reconnus on ne met pas de journée dans
l'année à nous pour pouvoir célébrer et
pour pouvoir se recueillir justement et
pouvoir réfléchir donc journée nationale
de réconciliation donc encore beaucoup
de travail à faire pour qu'une
réconciliation sur pied égale existe
mais aussi une journée pour célébrer
pour se découvrir pour sera compris que
cette histoire se répandent encore parce
que malgré le fait que la commission
vérité réconciliation a pris fin en 2015
et encore beaucoup qui maintient
ignorent l'histoire des pensionnés qui
ignorent même que ça existait donc c'est
encore un travail à faire pour les
décennies à venir mais on espère que ce
sera pas au travail il faut être faite
uniquement par les communautés
autochtones alors je vous souhaite une
bonne journée de la vérité de la
réconciliation